okay thank you for the introduction so
the results I am going to talk about
obtaining together with Federer Danielle
and sackett who are somewhere in this
building i believe and also these higher
brosman and bearish pattern as you can
see this results are not exactly new in
particular there are journal
publications already but it was not much
progress his problems and all this stuff
is about fine-grained complexity so I
decided to use this workshop as a
possibility to advertisers problems a
bit i'm going to talk about click needs
so unfortunately I have to introduce it
it's bit unpleasant but I am sure you
know the story behind Zach liquids you
know that many problems problems have
very nice algorithm properties for
graphs of bounded trivets and it's also
well know that for some dense graphs a
clicks co graphs many problems are very
easy so the idea is to was to generalize
trivet somehow then can pass such graphs
like co graphs and then they were
several at different attempts were
several different definitions that I in
fact equivalent but the most popular was
given by could sell an erotic scene is
appalling so I already mentioned co
graphs so this definition in this fact I
generalize the definition of Cobras one
of the definitions so suppose that we
have a graph G and the we have is some
positive integer t-80 graph is a graph
whose register sellable by integers from
1 to t so we have cholera graph and
because the thick graft insisted know if
exactly one vertex labret by the integer
any news
autograph and then the cliq weeds is a
smallest integer t such that our graph G
can be constructed by the application of
the following four operations so we can
construct initial T graphs then we can
take disjoint union that we can change
labels one color class the colors which
discovered by i 20 color J and finally
we can do join become connected which is
labeled by I with always discovered by
jailable bad shape so if t is 2 we have
exactly cobras so it can construct if we
can construct our graph so we have
expression for discussed afore for graph
G and then we can obtain parsing tree
our expression 3 responding to to this
construction so an expression tree of a
graph G is a really a rooted tree T so
the nodes of key are all four types they
correspond to operations so we have
introduced nodes that are leaves of the
expression tree so the corresponding
schulte graphs so then we have Union
notes the let's not have exactly to
achieve them and just know well and we
take you need joint union of children so
we have rebel and load for reliable
operation and we have joy notes for
generations so we demand that the graph
G is as a morphic to the graph
associated with the root of T without
labels and the leads of this
decomposition is the number of different
labels appearing in this let us consider
some simple example I won at least one
simple example to make it more clear
suppose that we have this graph
and we have this three so we first for
this branch say we introduce two
vertices X my web led by one and two say
we do disjoint Union so we have just
which is built without this edge then we
from join oh sorry
then we will variable matrix X by eight
color too so we have the switch square
by 2 then for this branch we introduced
to which says you can be colored by one
take the joint union take this joint
union here and take joint so we have
this edges so we have this expression
three for this craft so it's very easy
this case well the most famous result
about quickness is the following cafe
famous Syrian biker cell makovsky
neurotics that all problems that can be
expressed with manic psychologic order
logic one I fixed parameter tractable to
interim tries back liquids MSO one here
means that we have magnetic second-order
logic but we can quantify only over
vertex variable and variables k spooning
two sets of UTC's not we can not 25 our
edges well it's really there was active
research around about around this
theorem source rimini results and as
well as the results about when Grant
complexity so people were trying to
obtain some structural results when we
can get some beta dependence on F here
so there are really a mini lower bounds
well but this lever bound sorry earlier
for passage if we have a lower bounds
for passwords this lower bound can be
immediately translated to click it's
because this is at most passage pass one
but there are some there are many
problems that do not fit to this
language so whenever we are speaking
about we have h problems but we cannot
apply this serum so in particular we
cannot do it for covering passaic
Hamiltonian cycle and also for Mac Scott
is dominating sets of a mini national
property problems still as those
problems can be solved in polynomial
time but degree fo graphs of bonnet
creek is but in this case degree of
polynomial depends on and crickets and
in fact for exam ax cottage dominating
set covariant k colorings and
Hamiltonian pasa w1 Harper amatrice be
tickets so we cannot do it but I was to
obtain some fine grained upper and lower
bounds for particular these problems and
for Mark Scott and HD meeting set which
shows that this problems cannot be
solved in time f of T and small off T
and s 80 th collapses but from the other
side these problems can be solved in
time began to the Big O of T so this
result I really can be also obtained for
some variance of this problems for
example minimum or maximum by section
well something similar can be done for
some other problems in particular for
problem for double paradise graph
programs when where click the click this
is one of the parameters we have this
this results for dense or sparse k sub
graph problem this problem ask about k
bouticks induced sub graph is minimum
maximum number which edges and we show
that this problem can be solved for
example is from decibel can be certain
time k to the Big O of key but it can be
solved in time a two to the smaller of
tea okay after
well and the same holds for dat you are
induced sub graph problems and really it
can be done for some other but less
known problems results and for these
problems it's easy to obtain algorithmic
upper bounds for some of problems it's
maybe not stretch absolutely straight
forward but for example Mark Scott it's
almost trivial so if we have Mark Scott
then well we have discovered classes so
what is our word what we keep as partial
solution so we keep just a partition of
each color class and the maximum number
of edges in a cut for this partition
then it's easy to update tables well the
most difficult cases when we have joined
but then we always come tweak our and
expression so that we have no edges
between this color classes before the
separation and then we can just have to
count how many ages we had when we from
J so it's easy so so all the papers
really about a lower bounds and this is
non-trivial part and we start with k
click and the already know the story
behind k click from the previous talk so
it's known that k click can not be
solved in time n to the small of kmec a
dish file right so then we can translate
this result for our multicolored it can
click it's easy but then i would like to
advertise one additional problem that we
are we used as a tool for proving a
lower bound for all these problems
somehow this problem was not used for
other reductions I could see it maybe I
miss assumption but I still believe that
this problem could be very convenient
this is a really non-problem stated
domination
suppose that we have a red blue graph by
pata graph so we have red vs blue
vertices and four red vertices we are
given capacities in this case capacity
to 13 and we are looking for red
domination set so we want to dominate
blue boxes by red witnesses but each red
vertex can't dominate the number of blue
versus defined by its capacity for
example this vertex can't dominate two
vertices this vertex contaminate one
vertex this vertex can the main three
vertices so in this case for example we
have capacitate the dominating set of
size 2 these two vertices and this with
exterminate this and this and this
vertex the minute the retina minutes the
remaining vertices so we can prove that
also we have this problem and blue
capacitive dominica set and we really
have variants of this problem in some
variants a very nerve for example we can
consider a blue saturated capacity
demented in this variant which well each
vertex selected to be in the end
eliminating search should eliminate
exactly a capacity neighbors its
capacity neighbors no less no more you
cannot move but shouldn't the necklace
and we also can consider for example red
blue exact saturated capacity dominating
set so here we have I you should have a
capacity de minute set of size exactly K
so we have different variants of the
program and for all the sweaters we can
prove that up to eat each we cannot
solve this problem in time and to be a
small of t where t is really not click
weeds but feedback we exit and this
results result holds for very restricted
inputs really and that is why this
problem is convenient for reductions I'm
not going to show oh this reduction this
is a really nice reduction its
sophistication in sophisticated but I
can show one picture to convince you
that
we obtained very restricted inputs so we
are start with we start with
multicolored clicks so we have sets we I
bj from our for instance of multicolored
click so 4 inch that we introduce
vertices here here and join them like
this and also for each segment reduce
two vertices here and here so the
zestimates belong to this set and this
vertices correspond to this set so then
we also for each pair of color classes
will reduce one vertex and we introduced
which says that correspond to edges and
join them like this then we construct so
named Arabs we have here in this picture
three boxes but really the number of
vertices different so we have this
passes and we use this information and
capacities of red versus to encode
structure paragraph but well it's
probably not clear what we are doing
here but what what can be observed that
this cloud graph has basically unique
feedback vertex set we have a feedback
metric set of size 2 case so we have to
take this two vertices here and so we
are doing each which set which set from
is the instance of multicolored click so
we have a unique feedback with a set of
size 2 K and if we remove those vertices
we obtain basically our stars so not
that starts but we can say two stars so
we have all gasp a distance from 20
maximum two from this vertex and a
distance 2 from this week so we have
very special forest and moreover if we
take this feedback yet except so we can
observe that these vertices have unique
neighbors in our feedback vertex set so
it's simply so we have a very restricted
case here and it simplifies reductions
for example a using
it we can obtain the same results when
we parameterize this problem by clicking
its or click is by incident graphs
require it's important that we have
uniqueness were here for liquids it's
nice to have this property that they not
bound for them so we have this result
for red blue cap sedated the minute sets
saturated capacitated set exact
saturated capacity to attend I well I
still think that it's this problem can
be a nice tool problem for other
reductions okay using this possibility
to advertise this program okay well and
we are using this problem to show all
our lower bounds well as you can guess
the reductions are not easy so I'm not
going to show them here it's simply have
no time but I can give you maybe some
ideas how it works and why capsid
8american set is convenient let us
consider a hd- ting set so for this
problem we have a simplest reduction so
we show this setting for edge dominating
set so we have this further bound so how
everything works suppose that we have
instance of red blue exaggerated
capacity Dominican set then we are what
we do so we have capacity to 13 so we
blow up and we have extra exam capacity
the damage set here for more like this
so we blow up each vertex according to
its capacity so we replace each area to
attacks by false twins and the number of
this force it means exactly a capacity
then we are hung edges here and now
while I fellow can fetch the minute and
set so well we would like we have to
dominate the edges so if we have some
gadgets are hanging that are hanging
here so we would like to pick edges that
leads from this
reverses to this red vertices and then
we have our aim in our reduction is to
make them behave exactly as assignment
for capacitated domination so for
example want this edges to lead to this
vertex that is selected to belong to our
capacity Dominican set of course it's
well without additional cattitude ingots
would be strange so the sages could go
whatever they want but whenever is able
but we of course build up we put some
gadgets here and 4-h dominating set
society gadgets are not very complicated
so for example how can we do selection
gadget so if we have a gadget like this
so we have K vertices here and which is
here complete graph here so edges coming
here and maybe something here so we want
to dominate the edges we want to
dominate the switches so we have to
choose some guys here and we can choose
K of them you very well you like to
choose K of them so how are they behaved
so well we asked by selecting K edges we
really ensures that we dominate vertices
at I incident to K vertices here so we
have selection so just of course I an
idea so we have to proceed so but in
this way we can obtain our result but
it's not so straightforward so okay so
this is how we do it for the minute in
sets or well for max cut it's more
complicated but also we can do it for
some other problems for example if we
consider problems that are parametrized
by click with Samson girls we use not
original well not the result about k
click but we can see this result but
obtained by h10 of marks and set up so
about K times K click this variant of
multicolored click very H set of
partition have says it exactly k then
it's known that we cannot solve this
problem in time to to the small of que
lo que this 8-inch fails then using this
result then we can go all through all
steps so we can go from this very
particular click the capacitated
dominating set and then we are using
reduction from capacitate the minute set
to this program so we are building so
it's we proceed this way so we obtain
this a lower bounds and our tight
results now what about open problems in
fact I should admit that there is a big
hole and all this story I did not point
it explicitly but in all statements well
I was it was written that we cannot
solve this problem in this time even if
expression three of which T is given but
the problem is click leads that we don't
know how to get this expression tree so
we don't know how to for example how to
approximate liquids in a good way so
only way is to approach that is known is
to approximated as a parameter language
and then we you know that graphs of body
language have have body liquids but this
bount expires exponential so we get
exponential blow-up and in this sense
maybe tight bounds are not so interested
but it I believe that it makes the
following question a very interesting
what can we say about ramp it's well
people start doing algorithm its
problems parameterize barrar quits but
up tunable but rockets is a very
inconvenient parameter to construct
algorithms it's very non-trivial and but
it's still possible
results by can take our sail home other
people so for example independent set
can be solved in time acts like 220
square for unfits force a Hamiltonian
path commission ec t hamiltonicity can
be solved still in their ball is still
in double exponential time and place by
renkens so the question well can we
obtain some better upper bound for
outlets or maybe we can get better lower
bounds maybe there is some trade off so
quickly it is convenient for algorithms
but well we don't know how to compute
liquids Rutledge is better for
computation so we can use them Seban
duality here so we can do something so
but well it's very important it is very
inconvenient for others but maybe we can
get some lower bounds that shows it so
maybe it can be proved that we cannot
solve oh I don't know chem etonian
cycling the better than double
exponential time / impressed by Iraqis
we don't know and up to now well nice
enjoy was done in this direction so it
maybe it's not a difficult to obtain a
linear bounds lower bounds meanwhile I
have strong suspicions that if we go
through our reductions in very careful
way me by just some of them so we can
get a lower bounds for an fits but well
as s lower bounds are not so interesting
can be without upper bounds become a
source ask the question for example what
about problems like Hamiltonian cycle so
we have a rayleigh lower bound we can
show that we cannot solve Hamiltonian
cycle for graphs of trick is at most a
better as an end to the smaller of tea
but upper bound is quadratic so n to the
Big O of T Square
can we do better well we know that well
you know that for a long time people
could not so those something oddly
better than like Kate t to the t43 bits
if these rivets but then it was
breakthrough so or maybe something like
this can be done for tickets as well can
this new approaches for dynamic
programming / trivets somehow be
translated for crickets it's not clear
as it can be done maybe not so it's
different so let's still but also we can
ask some special more special version so
for example well it could be asking
where is a deliberate you sub graph what
can is it possible to have a title gas
meter per and lower bound for Sadie
regular induced sub graph when
parameterize by three vision food graph
thank you any questions
thanks again